some of Russia's highest ranking
generals have not been seen in public
since the Mutiny by Wagner mercenaries
last week the group's leader yevgeni
pagosian wanted the arrest of Russian
defense Ministry of fish officials he
accused them of incompetence in ordering
attacks on his Fighters U.S media
Reports say Russia's FSB Security
Service warned Armed Forces Chief
Valerie jerasimov about pregosian's
planned Rebellion giving him time to
avoid capture the Kremlin is dismissing
reports that duressimov's Deputy was
also given Advanced knowledge of the
Mutiny for more on this story let's
bring in yulier shapovalova who's in
Moscow for us Yulia what more do we know
about how this week's events have
impacted that leadership in the military
yeah it's interesting that both generals
have not been seen for several days
since the armed Rebellion last weekend
during the Rebellion progression a
blamed uh uh
Minister shoigu and chief of general
staff gerasimo for their incompetence
and the death of thousands of soldiers
and basically demanded both generals to
be handed over to him girasimov is the
commander of Russia's war in Ukraine and
there is no information about a grasmus
verabouts at the moment unlike General
garasimo commander-in-chief of Russia's
airspace a Force's General Sergey sura
vegan always enjoyed preggers
complementary comments about him and his
service a precursion called saravican
the only Army General who knew how to
fight they used to fight together in
Syria years ago where Surah vikan was
nicknamed siren Butcher and general
Armageddon during the recent armed
rebellion surovicin was among the first
ones first generals who released a video
addressing the mutineers recently
serovicin was commander of the joint
group of Russian forces in Ukraine from
October 2022 to January to January 2023
and since January has served as Deputy
commander of the joint group of Russian
forces in Ukraine so this story of the
missing generals started earlier when
the Washington Post and the New York
Times reported that a general Surah
vican might have known about Evgeni
pregosian's military Mutiny and the
Moscow times then Road a citing its
sources close to the ministry of defense
that Sergey saravican had been arrested
that information also appeared on on
some Russian telegram channels others
after refuted it well at the moment
there is no other evidence for that and
it's been reported that Sarah vikin
hasn't been in contact with his family
or colleagues for several days now
sources allege that the FSB is now
checking that he was complicit in the
rebellion and yesterday and June the
28th the Kremlin spokesperson Dmitry
pescal said there would be a lot of
speculation and gossip about the missing
generals but he neither confirmed nor
denied the information that they had
been questioned about the Rebellion so
all we can say is that the generals are
presumably being questioned about their
possible role in the Mutiny well another
interesting development of the story is
that according to a number of Russian
and belarussian sources Evgeni
pregursion has flown from Belarus in the
direction of Russia as his returning for
negotiations with the Russian officials
that's the latest from Moscow for you
plenty of moving parts thanks so much
for the update Julio chapovalova in
Moscow for us